Okay. So, okay. So, you believe that the
that the the Bible is
somewhat untrustworthy
because
it is physically made and has
um has gone through transmissions.
>> Yep. Yeah. Somewhat. I'll say u there's
at least some challenges I I find with
trying to believe it wholeheartedly. I I
do understand the struggle for some
people to believe in what appears to be
just fantasy, but in terms of
Christianity, I don't I don't think it's
the only truth. Uh I I think Jesus, if
we're going with Jesus and his message
to preach a certain gospel, it wasn't he
wasn't preaching himself or or uh as I
understand it to follow him solely. I
think
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
>> You read the Bible? I've read the Bible
quite a bit and you're saying that Jesus
did not teach him to did not preach
himself and did not preach to follow
himself solely.
>> Yeah. Uh as I believe and and have read
in the Bible and studied quite a bit,
Jesus's sole message was a kingdom as
opposed to himself.
>> And how do we get into that kingdom
according to Jesus?
that that's what that's why I wanted to
start with the question of how you
define Christianity because to me
whether it's Jesus or anybody else the
the goal is above and beyond just
following Jesus himself right if if
>> and that's that's that's okay so let me
um
get your thoughts on this
>> Yep. John 14.
>> And and while you look, um, you know, I
still want to give my applause to what
you're doing and what you're trying to
do.
>> Thanks, man.
>> Yep. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. All
right. So, John 14:6.
Jesus said to him, "I am the way, the
truth, and the life. No one comes to the
Father except through me."
So this seems to be a very clear
explicit
non-inclusive statement from Jesus
preaching himself as the only way to the
father which would be in the kingdom.
Right.
>> I I agree to a certain extent. So, and
I'm glad you brought this up because
this is exactly what I would have went
to for the counterargument, which is
>> Jesus is preaching that the goal is to
get to the father, not to adore and
praise and to spend your life focusing
on me, Jesus.
That that's my interpretation of this
and and uh the expression of Jesus
saying, "Hey, you can't get to the
father except through me." But I am not
the ultimate goal of
>> that's not true because that's not a
negation of him being the destination as
well. Both he and the father are the
destination. And he's saying you can't
get to the father unless you come
through him. Notice he actually says
something similar about himself. He says
that no one comes to him unless the
father draws him
right to to Jesus. So um what's what's
that verse, Nick? Do you do you know
that verse or do I got to use Google?
Uh, I draw them.
>> Google.
>> Why don't you say Google?
>> No. No.
>> John's John 644.
>> Huh?
>> John 644.
>> Yeah, that's what I said.
>> Yeah, that's what I heard you say, too.
>> All right. For sure. For sure. Right. I
said that, right, Rev?
>> Yeah.
>> See, got haters in the chat, man.
>> All right. Look. So, look. He says, "No
one can come to me." Right? So he's the
destination unless the father who sent
me draws him and I will raise him up on
the last day.
Right? So similarly how you can't get to
the father unless you go through Jesus.
You can't get through to to Jesus unless
the father draws you. Mhm.
>> So, if we're looking at this verbatim,
he's saying you can't come to me
unless the father draws you to me. But
>> that doesn't at least read to me that
coming to him is the the final end all
beall, right? Because you still have
>> the original verse that
>> coming through to me or through me is to
get to the father,
>> right? So notice notice notice in in in
the first one I showed you
>> no one comes to the father. So we're
coming to the father.
>> Same language coming to right who we're
coming to the
>> father ex through Jesus.
>> Yep.
>> Here we're coming to Jesus. Come to me
unless the father. So it's through the
father that you got to get through to
get to Jesus.
>> Okay. Uh to to me that still reads you
got to come to the so so I don't know if
you study uh Miles Monroe at all. He has
a a um a good analogy for this. He says
Jesus is the door and and God is all of
the uh the destination inside whatever
the um uh place of worship might be. And
we spend so much time looking and
worshiping the door as opposed to coming
through the door to get to to God. And
it's up to whomever you might be to
determine if for yourself if if Jesus is
the actual door to get through to the
creator of all things. Um, but to me
this reads as Jesus is saying, "Hey,
whether you come to me or come through
me, you got to do one or the other in
order to get to to the father."
>> Nope. So again, we're taking it as it
is.
>> Mhm.
>> No one can come to me. So we're going to
Jesus, right? We're trying to get to
him. He's the destination according to
this phrase, right?
So
I I I don't I don't read that to say
coming to Jesus is the destination.
>> But you read you read it you read that
for the father. You said see it says
come to the father that means that the
father is the destination. So you're
being inconsistent here bro.
>> I I I understand
you're you're completely right and
understand in in what you're saying in
terms of the comes to versus comes to. I
I completely understand the consistency
in that point. I think you and I agree
at least the end result is to get to the
father. You can come to a door and you
could come to whatever's behind or
inside of that door.
>> But that's this where we disagree is
where you're where you're you're leaving
out Jesus. Jesus doesn't leave himself
out. That's the point. He says that you
got to come to the father and you got to
come to him. They're both the
destination, bro.
>> So, this is kind of hearkens back to my
first point, which is one, where do we
stand with the translation here, but
two, if we're going to take ex we're
going to
>> go ahead.
>> If if we're going to take exactly what's
written here, I do think that yes, you
can come to a door or come to whatever
gets you through to the next. It's kind
of a series of of progression here,
right? You can come to a door and you
can come to whatever is inside. If the
goal is to get to whatever's inside, you
would both come to the door and come to
whatever is inside. But that doesn't
change the fact that whatever's inside
is the destination.
>> Okay? And so I want to show you
something else, too.
>> I just I just want to because I just
want to confirm whether or not I'm
making sense to you all at least on that
point.
>> No, sir.
>> Okay. Okay. The pro and the problem is,
bro, is because it just it that's not
what the verse says and you're being
inconsistent with how you're reading one
verse. But when it says the exact same
thing and same phrase for Jesus, you're
like, "Oh, well, no, he's not the
destination here." But when it for the
father, when it says come to the father,
oh yeah, he's the destination. You can't
you can't be inconsistent like this.
Now, now watch this. So, same chapter of
the way, truth, and life. Come to the
father except through me. He says, ' Let
not your hearts be troubled. Believe in
God. Believe also in me. In my father's
house are many rooms. If it were not so,
I would not would I have told you that I
go to prepare a place for you. And if I
go and prepare a place for you, I will
come again and will take you to myself
that where I am you may be also, and you
know the way to where I'm going. And he
talks about how he's the way to where
he's going. So, do you see how Jesus
says he's the destination? How I will
come again to take you
>> to myself?
>> It's a good one.
>> I I completely agree in that
perspective.
>> No, no, no. I I completely I completely
agree in that perspective. What I think
he is communicated here is taking you to
myself in the sense of him being the
father
>> where
>> Oh, come on, man. I I'll let you finish
though. Sorry. I didn't
>> What I'm saying is that he's not going
to take YOU TO HIMSELF.
>> WHAT?
>> S Hold on one second. Let me finish.
>> He's not going to take you to himself
separate from
>> him taking you to the father. Okay,
that's what I mean by that point. Okay,
good. what I'm trying to communicate in
terms of the coming to I've always read
and learned that verse as no one comes
uh to the father except through me right
>> yes
>> so if that's the case then
>> to drill down on the analogy a bit if
Jesus is
>> let's just say is this door and God is
the couch in the house the goal is to
get to the couch in the house not to
come to the for
>> I hate Dr. Seuss.
>> What's that?
>> N Dr. Seuss reference.
>> Yeah, I just couch in the house. I got
you.
>> Yeah, couch in the house. Couch in the
house is boss.
>> That's all I'm trying to say. There's a
nuance here. And I think broader than
the tradition of Christianity, I I think
the belief in the gospel of the kingdom
itself, not just Jesus Christ. uh to
spend our time in the tradition of
worshiping and all of that as opposed to
bringing the kingdom here on earth is is
the nuance that I I I was trying to
make. I we understand and here's here's
why you're close and so far at the same
time is because you said how you
understand this where Jesus says I'm
going to take you to myself that when
he's taking you taken us to himself it's
not separate from the father that it's
he's taking us to him and to the father
right and that's the point the point is
is that both the father and the son are
the destination
just because we see here him Say no one
can come to me unless the father draws
the father draws him doesn't mean
doesn't exclude the father from being
the destination as well that the one who
we want to get to as well just like when
he says I am I'm the way I'm the way the
truth and the life no one comes to the
father except through me that doesn't
exclude Jesus from being the destination
also which is why in the same context he
says I will Come and I will take you to
myself. Where's the destination? Jesus
has taken us to himself which is in
union with the father. It's not
separate. It's not a separate thing.
Together they are the destination.
>> I I I hear you. U and and I don't
>> Is that what it says?
>> I agree that this is what this says.
>> Okay. So what we talking about there,
man? We're that's why I was asking for
us to define Christianity because if
we're talking about Christianity from a
tradition standpoint versus the the
practical pure belief in Jesus and uh
and and the father in whatever sense
anyone can argue I I think those are two
completely different things. So if we're
ar if we're defining Christianity as the
tradition and the name in the construct
of whatever denomination you want to
pick then that's one thing and that's
what I would object to. The goal of
getting to the father, whether you
identify the father as, you know, a
triune being or just the creator of all
things or whatever the case might be,
the goal is to have an intimate
relationship with the creator of all
things. However you can, however you can
get there. That's why, you know,
tradition and religion um is is tough
for many people, including including
myself. Where do you get this idea from
that the goal is to have an intimate
relationship with the creator?
>> Um, well, one
kind of trying to uh study as much as I
can across many different religions and
practices also some self-searching and
what rings or feels true to me.
>> So, not the Bible. The Bible is a
portion of that, of course, a big
portion because of my upbringing. My dad
was and is a pastor. Uh but we defer on
on quite a bit in our approach to the
tradition of Christianity. What what
does So, forget the tradition of
Christianity. We're talking about what
the Bible says and what Jesus brought.
um like and when I say forget the
tradition of Christianity, I mean this
idea of however we grew up and or going
to church and what you've seen like I
guess culturally, but more so what does
the scripture teach and you could look
at how it was taught throughout true
Christianity
>> from the folks who followed the
disciples. So when we're looking at
Christianity, it's father, son, and holy
spirit.
Jesus the son came died for our sins.
Came in the flesh. Died for our sins in
the course of the flesh and rose again
on the third day. All right? And that
salvation is in his name alone. Um and
that it's by his grace and his
righteousness that we are made
righteous. That's the message of
Christianity.
>> Amen.
>> And and if Jesus didn't rise,
Christianity is false. There is no
resurrection if Jesus did not rise from
the dead. That's Christianity.
So, do you disagree with that? Because
Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Um,
uh, I'll say no except for the fact that
how do we account for those who have
never received the message from birth to
death?
So, first Peter actually talks about
that. Read 1 Peter chapter 3:1 18-21.
Something called the herring of Hades
where Christ went and preached to the
realm of the dead. He went to preach to
the spirits that were imprisoned. He
does that because that includes people
who never heard Christ. So, if someone
never heard of Christ, we still believe
they'll have the opportunity to accept
him. That's why he went and preached to
the spirits in prison. This is something
that's not simply a temporal action, but
it's something that occurs over eternity
itself, right? So, anybody either before
Christ or after Christ that didn't hear
about Christ will have the opportunity.
He gives everyone the opportunity to do
that.
>> Yeah. Um and I appreciate it and and and
I would love to agree to that point. Uh
I I don't know that that's something
that we can uh argue has its evidence
other than what's been asserted in the
Bible itself which doesn't reach the
level of circular but um is is only as
good as one might believe in that
portion of of the Bible itself. uh but
but there is definitely some challenge
with for myself but also I'm sure for
many people who want to believe that uh
those many people who have never heard
and will never hear the the message of
the Bible uh will just be presented with
an opportunity to believe after they
die. um
and and where that might stand in uh uh
emphasizing the veracity of the Bible as
a whole. I that just is at least for me
in my conscious mind is a a bridge too
far. U to take that as rationale to say
hey the Bible from front to back with
copyright and all is the undeniable word
of God. Um, I I do like So, so now we're
kind of segueing from what the Bible
actually teaches itself to whether or
not it's reliable or not. So, um, so
like before we get there, can we agree
that with what we've seen Jesus
he preached a an exclusive message?
>> Yes, I I do believe Jesus preached an
exclusive message. To me, that message
was the kingdom of heaven.
which which we can't get through unless
it's through him. Correct. And the
father.
>> That's what he preached. Correct.
>> Okay. Now, in going to Okay. Well, why
should we believe this stuff in the
first place? You know, is the Bible
reliable or not? What what what makes
you think that because the Bible went
through transmissions
um that somehow there's parts of it that
can't be relied upon anymore? Yeah.
>> Uh I'm not sure I you're saying because
it's taken different form over years
that it can't be
>> let let's take let's take this like when
you say taken different form over the
what do you mean by that taking
different forms? Well, the uh emissions
or reversions from translation to
translation or um the
for lack of a better term that the Bible
was crowdsourced over over uh different
years and in eras u and then to have
>> I don't know what that means
>> as in as in there were a lot of
different contributors to to the Bible.
What a the funny part about this is it
actually makes the Bible more reliable.
>> Right. I'm getting to that point. I'm
not I'm not disagreeing with that. Yeah.
I'm not the Bible more reliable.
>> I'm not disagreeing with having more
more uh contributors to the Bible over a
certain time period uh can make it more
reliable. But I also do believe that it
also can undermine the Bible quite a bit
because you have positions of power over
centuries who can make influential
decisions about what ultimately ends up
becoming
>> the
>> that's it's the opposite brother. Okay.
So we have something in the Bible called
an open transmission. For example, the
Quran would have something called a
closed transmission which means it's
controlled by a group. The Bible doesn't
have that. There is no group, single
group that has the authority to
translate the Bible. Anyone can. Mere
logic can go translate the Bible. We can
go do it ourselves. That makes it more
reliable because what you just said is
now someone in power can go and they can
change things. That can't happen in
Christianity because we have an open
transmission. So if one group does go
and change something, well, guess what?
The thousand other groups, it'll be
different. So we'll know it's not
changed.
>> Yeah. I think I think that's accurate
about today. I don't think that's
accurate about the past 2,000 years and
and where along the way there have been
uh concerted efforts to be able to
address what should be included in the
Bible and what shouldn't.
>> Well, I I don't know what you mean. I
mean, there's been no there was never
any centralized group though that
translated the Bible itself. There's
been centralized groups that maybe have
described the canon, but there's been no
centralized group ever that's been the
only one to translate the Bible. It's
just never been a thing.
>> Yeah, I I would have to disagree because
we have at least the Bible itself has a
finite number of books in it, right? And
how does that
Yeah, I said the canon is I agree there
is a specific group that decides the
canon. I said what there's not a
specific group for though has ever been
is translation or transmission. Again,
whether we're talking about translation
or transmission, the actual composition
has had influence or or has been
produced by some influence over however
many years or or centuries. That that's
just one note. And and I know we're not
the conversation diverting a bit here,
but
that I'm trying to describe to you.
>> That's on point. You're talking about
why you're talking about why you don't
really trust the Bible fully and you're
saying that because well, we got to the
point as far as what what I'm
understanding is that because there was
a you know a a group that had influence
over the canonization of the Bible that
therefore
there's there's it's it's unreliable
now. But I don't I don't I don't see why
that's that follows though. Well, one
because if if the term is canonization,
uh then then
uh it it makes reference to what's
included in the Bible and what isn't.
>> Uh for
>> they had an objective standard to judge
why, what books go in and and don't.
>> Okay? And and it would be for each
individual believer to blindly accept
that their rationale was actually
objective. That that's one. Second is
again from from translation to
translation uh there are minute but you
know some incidents of omissions.
>> Have you have you ever looked in early
early church like the early church
history
>> not not much briefly but not much.
>> Yeah. So when it came to the
canonization of the Bible, bro, there
wasn't they didn't have to blindly
follow um people like these people
aren't idiots and you know uh having
talks within a secret room and then
saying, "Hey guys, we figured it out."
No, there were councils, large councils
with a lot of people there, right? uh
with with leaders and bishops of these
of these churches there. People who knew
the disciples and apostles who studied
under them and knew the apostles and you
know so they they have an objective
standard of what belongs written by an
actual apostle of Jesus because we know
who they are. We learned from them
ourselves and walked with them. We know
what's an authoritative epistle from an
apostle. was inspired by God was written
by a prophet, right? Um or someone who
knew the apostle, an eyewitness, a
companion of them, they this is how they
judged um and the the books and so and
it actually helped pick out false books
that would come out later by the
Gnostics and others who would come up
and would throw on a name like the
Gospel of Mary or something like that.
And the church is able to recognize that
ain't it because Mary's gone. Mary
didn't write anything. We know the
people who walked with Jesus and who
walked with the people who walked with
Jesus and we have their tradition and
their history carried on with us. This
is falsehood.
>> I I'm I'm with you. Uh but to the point
and and to clarify what I was saying is
believers today would have to have blind
faith in the process back then.
>> No, that's what I was We don't have to
have blind faith in the process because
we can look at the history of the
process and the historical backing of
it. That's that's the point like like
for example I I I can trust Polycarp
because Polycarp was a direct disciple
of John.
>> So Polycarp is carrying the tradition of
John and others like Ignatius carrying
on the tradition of the apostles you
know and then Aronyaeus who comes after
Polycarp carrying these traditions on
and so on and so forth. the succession,
right? So, the historicity lines up. We
don't have to blindly, oh, well, it just
is what it is. We can look at the
historicity of it and see that it all
lines up.
>> I I hear you. But that would then
presuppose that as a a believer in any
sense today, I would have to undeniably
believe that no level of uh uh
what makes human beings flawed had any
factor in the process back then
>> to believe that the Bible itself is
unflawed today. Right.
>> Well, well, this is what I would think.
I would think that you if you're gonna
hold a hypers skeptical view
uh like don't be hyper skeptical you
there there's you can be skeptical in a
fair way reasonably skeptical right what
I'm saying is is that follow the
evidence where it leads maybe it doesn't
convince you wholeheartedly like oh I
got 100% proof because I was you wasn't
there you know you you weren't there 200
years ago 800 years ago 1400 you wasn't
there right you can rely you're you're
relying on historicity and testimony and
and collaboration. That that's what
you're relying on, the historical
method. So, he wasn't there. However,
>> with that being said, you follow the
evidence where it leads, the history and
the ev and and the amount of history
where it leads and make a reasonable
decision to put your trust in the
evidence, right? And then also on top of
that, look at the opposing side. Like if
you're going to say, "Hm, you know what?
Maybe there was some corruption that
happened with the with the scriptures
based on what? What evidence do we have
that there is tampering uh corruption
uh theological corruption uh purposeful
planned tampering with the scripture
that went unnoticed that seeped into the
scriptures um that nobody caught? Like
what evidence would we have of that?
You know what I'm saying?
>> Yeah, I'm with you on that. What you're
saying denotes a level of intention
whether So what I'm saying is whether
intentionality or not, there has to be
some level of flaw in the process to
produce.
>> Why?
>> Be be because we're human beings and
anything that we produce has some level
of of flaw in imperfection.
>> I don't know, man. My mama produced me,
man. I came out pretty nice, man.
>> Hey. Hey. not really good.
>> That that makes one of us. But but what
what I'm saying is that I understand
where people who want to believe can't
get there because it's saying basically
we have to have this trust in this
process that took place that we weren't
there for. And whether we followed the
evidence or not, if we followed the
evidence and came up with the
conclusion, it would still require us to
say that okay, the process there
produced a perfect book. And I'm not
sure how anyone can come to that
conclusion. The only way that you the
only flaw that you would see cuz I agree
that humans make mistakes and the
mistakes that we see are scribal,
copiest errors, misspellings, double
lines, you know, that type of stuff.
You're not going to see any uh doctrinal
uh mistakes or contradictions
within the manuscripts
which points to God's sovereign rule and
control over his word and his message.
>> Yeah. Um you know that would mean God's
word is delivered to man's hand without
any any any flaw. Uh which then stands
the reason as to why that doesn't happen
today. Because
>> what do you mean? What what do you mean
why that doesn't happen? Like why why
don't we get other revealed scripture?
Why doesn't God give us more scripture?
>> Oh, simple. Because he says it in the
scripture that the law and the prophets
were until John, but now the gospel of
the kingdom is being proclaimed and that
Jesus is the seal. He has the seal of
the father. He's it. So the message of
the gospel and through the apostles who
are filled with the holy spirit to
spread the message and to uh you know
bring a basis and ground the church.
That's that was for that they were the
ones to build the church. That's in the
Bible that the Bible tells us that
I I hear you. um the the it it just to
me that doesn't uh pass the smell test
that you could have the apostles then
that hear the word of God that can write
it down and now no man has the right to
be able to hear the word of God to write
it down it and it be considered just as
valid uh as as the gospel itself that
that that ultimately where at least the
challenge in the mindset that says says
the Bible is perfect. There is nothing
that can be do that can be done to
change the word of God or question it
because it's already been tested. Uh
that that's just where I personally find
challenge because I think if you're a
believer, you would like to think that
you hear the word of God as well. And if
you wrote it down then then then what is
it not as true as what we find in
Matthew, Mark, Luke and John?
>> Yeah. We don't walk in the office of the
apostles. The apostles were the founders
of the church. See that's and and Christ
is the one who set them up for that. So
he set them up set them up to found the
church. set them up to teach the church
in its Genesis, in its beginning as it
grew. And the writings of the apostles
filled with the Holy Spirit
is what the Christians
uh appeal to for um for the word of God
and godly living. You know, and like I
said, when you go out through the
scriptures, Jesus tells you that there
is no other message after the gospel.
It's the gospel. That's it. I can't come
out and say, "Hey man, I heard from God.
Write something down and say this is
divine revelation. This is I can't."
That's that's not our office unless you
God cracks the sky and can tell you
that. But
>> I hear you. I hear you. You know,
questions still exist, I think. But I I
appreciate the the time here in the back
and forth.
>> My wife got dinner for me. Uh hopefully
you guys are are doing well and have a
good evening. I'll keep the stream
running, but but thank you for your time
and and I'll keep up with the content,
man. Bless you. Bless you both.
>> God bless, man. Thanks for the
conversation, man.
>> Yep, man. Have a good one.
>> You, too.
>> All right.
>> What' you think, Nick?
>> It's been good, man. I feel like we've
had we've had some a decent amount of
people that have seemed to been open and
seemed to, you know, potentially change
their mind. I don't know if he will. He
seems to be contending with everything.
I hope he does, though. Um, hope he
looks at the evidence and, you know,
sees
>> seems to be hyper skeptical. Like, he's
a hyper skeptic,
>> specifically historically. Yeah, it
seems to be, which just doesn't make any
sense because then you just can't trust
anything in history anymore.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I would I would encourage
him to really look into early church
history, man.
>> Look into early church history. And I I
encourage every Christian to do that.
I'm doing that myself. And man, the
>> the evidence for Christianity, it's
historically astounding.
>> It is
>> just historically astounding, you know.
Um, man, it it's it's it's awesome. It's
it's I Everybody get into early church
history, please. Please get
>> strengthening your faith a lot. That's
for sure. Heavier face.